breaking news alert
breaking here at six o'clock a student
accused of sexually assaulting and then
trying to kill his teacher thanks for
joining us i'm denise valdez and i'm
christian casadas 8 news now i-team's
david charns digging into the
investigation and david you have
reaction from both the staff and
students yeah the incident just the
latest in reported violence inside our
schools and those we talked to today say
this is just a boiling point the head of
the teachers union saying maybe teachers
shouldn't come back after spring break
until more is done to protect their
safety
if what happened yesterday does not
enlighten the community as well as ccsd
i don't know what else is it going to
take the president of the clark county
education association says enough is
enough is it going to take someone dying
at the hands of a student you know
whether it's another student or a staff
member we have to have some immediate
interventions to
figure out what to do what to do after
the latest case of violence at ccsd
sources telling the 8 news now i-team a
janitor found this teacher in her
classroom after school thursday
according to police she was in her room
when this 16-year-old student came in to
talk about grades
at some point police say that student
got violent punching and strangling the
teacher until she lost consciousness
he's also accused of sexually assaulting
her students out of class friday
afternoon say they were stunned after
that situation everybody's
weirded out they say this teacher is
well known and well liked crazy to be
honest never really thought that this
could actually happen at the school with
school now closed for a week for spring
break the union president says teachers
want to feel safe when they return they
want an immediate intervention to happen
to occur
to make the bill safer about being on
those campuses
in the message ccsd superintendent dr
jesus jarrah says he is in part
devastated he also says quote our hearts
are heavy because of the violence
committed against her and we pray for
her full recovery now because of his age
the student would face charges as an
adult students return to class a week
from tuesday i'm david charns live local
now